GILBERT STRANG: OK.
This is our last look at the
first order linear differential
equation that you see up here.
The dy dt is ay, that's
the interest rate growing
in the bank example.
y is our total balance.
And q of t is our
deposits or withdrawals.
Only one change.
We allow the interest rate
a to change with time.
This we didn't see before.
Now we will get a formula.
It will be a formula we had
before when a was constant.
And now we'll see it.
It looks a little messier, but
the point is, it can be done.
We can solve that
equation by a new way.
So that's really
the other point.
Everybody in the end likes
these integrating factors.
And I will call it m.
And let me show you what
it is and how it works.
What it is is the solution
to the null equation,
with a minus sign.
With a minus sign. dM
dt equals minus a of tM.
No source term.
We can solve that equation.
If a is constant-- and I'll keep
that case going because that's
the one with simple,
recognizable formulas.
If a is a constant, we're
looking for the function
M whose derivative is minus aM.
And that function is
e to the minus at.
The derivative brings down
the minus a that we want.
In case a is varying, we can
still to solve this equation.
It will still be an
exponential of minus something.
But what we have
to put here when
I take the derivative of
M, the derivative of that
will come down.
So I want the
integral of a here.
And then the derivative of
the integral is a minus a,
coming down as it should.
So I want minus
the integral of a.
And can I introduce dummy
variables, say a of T dT,
just to make the
notation look right.
OK.
You see that, again,
the derivative of M
is always with an exponential.
It's always the exponential
times the derivative
of the exponent.
And the derivative of
that exponent is minus a.
Because by the fundamental
theorem of calculus,
if I integrate a and take its
derivative, I get a again.
And it's that a that I want.
Now, why do I want this M?
How does it work?
Here's the reason M succeeds.
Look at the derivative
of M times y.
That's a product.
So I'll use the product rule.
I get the derivative
of y times M,
and then I get the
derivative of M times y.
But the derivative of
M is minus a of tM,
so I better put the derivative
of M is minus a of tM times y.
But what have I got here?
Factor out an M and
that's just dy dt
minus ay, dy dt minus ay is q.
So when I factor out
the M, I just have q.
All together, this is M times q.
Look, my differential
equation couldn't look nicer.
Multiplying by M
made it just tell us
that a derivative is
a right-hand side.
To solve that equation, we
just integrate both sides.
So if you'll allow me to take
that step, integrate both sides
and see what I've
got, that will give us
the formula we know when
we're in the constant case,
and the formula we've never
seen when t is varying.
And then I'll do an example.
Let me do an example right away.
Suppose a of t, instead of
being constant, is growing.
The economy is really
in hyperinflation.
Take that example if a
of t is, let's say, 2t.
Interest rate started
low and moves up,
then growth is going to be
faster and faster as time
goes on.
And what will be
the integral of 2t?
The integral of 2t is t
squared, so M, in that case,
will be e to the
minus a t squared.
Sorry, there's no a anymore.
a is just the 2t.
e to the minus t squared.
With a minus sign,
it's dropping fast.
In a minute, we'll
have a plus sign there
and we'll see the growth.
Do you see that this is the
integrating factor when a of t
happens to be 2t?
OK.
Now I come back to this
equation and integrate
both sides to get the answer.
OK.
All right.
The integral of My,
of the derivative,
the integral of the
derivative is just
M of t y of t minus
M of 0 y of 0.
That's the integral
on the left side.
And on the right side,
I have the integral
of M times q from 0 to t.
And again, I'm going to
put in an integration
variable different from t
just to keep things straight.
OK.
So now I've got a formula for y.
It involves the M. Actually,
the y is multiplied by M,
I better divide by-- first of
all, do we remember what M of 0
is?
That's the growth factor at 0.
It's just 1.
Nothing's happened.
It's the exponential of 0 in
our formulas for M. M of 0 is 1.
That's where M starts.
So M of 0 is 1.
I can remove that.
OK.
And now-- oh, let me put that on
the other side so this will be
equals y of 0 plus that.
OK.
And now if I divide by
M, I have my answer.
So those are the steps.
Find the integrating factor.
Do the integration,
which is now made easy
because I have a perfect
derivative whose integral I
just have to integrate.
And then put in what M is, and
divide by it so that I get y.
OK.
So I'm dividing by M.
So what is 1 over M?
Well, M has this minus
sign in the exponent.
1 over M will have a plus sign.
M here has e to the
minus t squared.
1 over M will be e to
the plus t squared.
So when I divide
by M, I get y of t.
This will be 1 over M. That will
be e to the plus the integral
of a of t dt y of 0.
That's the null solution.
That's the solution that's
growing out of y of 0.
And now I have plus the integral
from 0 to t of-- remember,
I'm dividing by M. And
that's e to the plus
the integral from 0 to
s of a times q of s ds.
OK.
Oh, just a moment.
I'm dividing by M
and I had an M there.
Oh, wait a minute.
I haven't got it right here.
So I want to know what is M at
time s divided by M at time t?
So this was the
integral from 0 to s.
This is an integral from 0 to t.
And both are in the exponent.
This is-- can I say it here?
This is a e to the-- divided by
M is the integral from 0 to t.
And then I'm multiplying by e
to the minus the integral from 0
to s.
The rule for
exponents is if I have
a product of two exponentials,
I add the exponents.
When I add this to
this, this knocks off
the lower half of the integral.
I'm left with the
integral from s to t of a.
So this was an integral of
a minus an integral of a.
Let me do our example.
Our example up here.
Example-- M of t will be--
when a is equal to 2t,
this was the example
a equal to 2t.
The first time we've been able
to deal with a varying interest
rate.
So the integral of
2t is t squared.
From the-- is e
to the t squared.
And I subtract the
lower limit, s squared.
That's the growth factor.
That's the growth factor
from time s to time t.
When a was constant,
that exponent
was just a times t minus s.
That told us the time.
But now, a is varying and
the growth factor between s
and t is e to the t
squared minus s squared.
So that's what goes in here.
Let me-- that's
the growth factor.
May I just put it in here?
In this example, it's e to
the t squared minus s squared.
Instead of e to the
a t minus s, I now
have t squared minus
s squared, because I
had an integral of a of t,
and a is not constant anymore.
This is my example.
And I don't know if
you like this formula.
Can I just describe it again?
This was an integral
from 0 to t,
so that would be-- this part
would be e to the t squared.
That's the growth factor that
multiplies the initial deposit.
The growth factor
that multiplies
the later deposit is e to the
t squared minus s squared.
And we allow deposits all
the way from s equals 0 to t.
So when we add those
up, we get that sum.
We've solved an
equation that we hadn't
been able to solve before.
That's a small triumph in
differential equations.
Small, admittedly.
I'd rather move next to
non-linear equations, which
we have not touched.
And that's a big deal.
Thank you.